the united states air force thunderbirds
reached out and asked if i was ready to
fly in an f-16
i reluctantly said yes
i'm gonna pass out i mean there's
there's no other way about it i'm going
to pass out
that's just going to drain out your
skull i'm a little dizzy we can uh
okay take a quick pause do you feel like
you have an elephant sitting on your
chest
one two three one two three
one two three
had to wake up 4am so
you can bet i didn't sleep much even
though the explicit instructions were
sleep a good night's sleep they also
said have a heavy breakfast
or at least a good breakfast i had a
protein bar oh and a banana
we're trying to enter the air force base
but apparently they said we don't know
who you are
apparently the pentagon did not send our
clearance
through to this spot right here and
because of that
oh my god plane landing i was afraid to
do this
what was i afraid of you may ask well
the heights for one then not knowing
what it's gonna feel like two and three
i was worried about g-lock g-force
induced loss of consciousness
okay first of all what is g-force
g-force is a poorly received 2009 disney
film about a team of secret agent guinea
pigs
g-force is also a measurement of the
force of gravity on our bodies in
everyday life we have
one g of force on us that's the earth's
standard force of gravity our bodies are
well acclimated to this
so we're gonna get you up to nine g's
today a really wicked roller coaster
it's like three to four g's give or take
at one g let's say you weigh 200 pounds
at nine g's you can weigh 1800 pounds
please do what gravity tells them to
in this case the blood is gonna drain
out of your skull so as your heart beats
it's trying to have the blood move up
but there's way too much force pushing
it down as a result you don't get enough
circulation you don't get enough oxygen
going to the brain you g-lock you pass
out
how you feeling sir the only way to
fight that one i'm gonna be wearing a
very special suit
that helps squeeze my lower body in
order to help push some of this blood
back up into my body the second thing
is something known as the anti-g
straining maneuver
ready now good good good clench good
clenching basically what i needed to do
learn to squeeze my entire lower body
and try and keep my blood up here
and you're doing a breathing technique
where you're exhaling
very short breaths against a closed
glottis
one two three one two three
one two three because if you don't if
you let's say go
good luck taking a big deep breath in
you feel like you have an elephant
sitting on your chest
this will be the t-shirt you wear
underneath this is gonna be your flight
suit so it's like one big
pajama onesie okay and then these are
your boots size 11.
okay yep all right they make it sound so
easy sam
no it's not you said you'll be giggling
at nine g's i think
i somehow don't think that's it wait
didn't you say can't have synthetics on
i think i'm wearing synthetic underwear
i haven't worn boots like this ever well
i would not be a good soldier
everyone who wears this patch we have to
work our way up to it so it's an honor
to wear this patch and today
you get to work
i am ready to not eject out of this
aircraft
okay perfect
good do you feel like you have a good
seal yeah inhale
hold one two three exhale
yep and take the helmet off perfect
they taught me about the eject lever in
between my legs but they also
consistently told me do not pull it
unless you truly need to eject
apparently someone in the past
they were so anxious being inside the
cockpit that they just pulled it to
escape
out next walks in lieutenant colonel
kevin defalco and he tells me
everything we're about to do in this
plane and i'm not gonna lie
my anxiety was at an all-time high i'm
gonna pass out i mean there's
there's no other way about it i'm gonna
pass out you'll be fine i promise
if i can do it you can do it i'm like
5-1
yeah but that makes it better for you
you're more
protected from the g-forces short and
female
to be honest like they sound very
reassuring when they talk to you but
i think that the reassurance maybe one
of those like
make him think he'll be okay so he will
be okay so i don't think i'm gonna be
okay
but i i might be okay
the storm
i've been gone is a while but don't be
scared
right now i don't know if i'll ever
famous last words this was a bad idea
there's 250 miles an hour
final
at the ground speed we're going 395
miles per hour ground speed
ready to go yeah all right good breath
here come the cheese
i'm starting to lose my vision my heart
is working in overdrive to try and bring
the blood back from my lower body to my
brain
all right next we're going to go into a
loop you ready go for the loop okay good
breath
[Music]
staring inside the cockpit was a really
bad idea it caused a sensory conflict
between what my eyes were seeing and
what my inner equilibrium was feeling as
a result
i got really nauseous gonna bring it all
the way through
we're gonna keep going you can see our
smoke there's our smoke
look up and you can see the smoke
there's our loop how about that pretty
cool
i'm a little dizzy we can uh okay take a
quick pause
all right we calibrate here yeah all
right we're gonna get down here we're
gonna do a knife edge next okay
ready to go yep all right here we go
we're just cruising along the clouds 90
degree angle
nice and straight one key straight down
now left side right
yep here we go
all right you ready to roll 360 degrees
yeah here we go
rolling it there we go inverted again
take a look at the clouds how fast
they're moving yeah good friends
here come the cheese
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he was a little nervous this morning
about what the maneuvers are going to be
like and how we were going to do
but i'll tell you he got through the
entire profile today we did everything
because you're probably curious what he
did in terms of g's
he did pull 9.2 g's
it could not have been done without
everyone here so i have to give everyone
a huge thank you for allowing me to
participate this is a once in a lifetime
experience that i'm going to be telling
my followers my patients
so thank you again and thank you gator
for getting me back safely
thanks for keeping keeping everybody
healthy and happy
and inspiring your followers to live a
better life
and that's important to us too i was so
nervous i know i was a little worried
you were so
nervous during the briefings but after
that first one
i knew i could handle it yeah came close
to graying out a couple of times
but i noticed as i adjusted my muscles
and i wasn't squeezing let's say my
abdomen enough
or my glutes enough once i adjusted
right away the vision came back
let's get this video to 100 000 likes
let's continue
our mission with the united states air
force let's see some cool stuff let's
see the medical side of it
let's see what uh being a doctor in the
air force is like i'm working and flying
every day
with my patients if you want to do that
definitely hit like
check out this video of me saving a life
on an airplane or this video here
where i actually fly a different
airplane and hold some incredible
animals
actually interact with the animals like
both are really good watches which one
you're going to watch
as always stay happy and healthy